you've got to be honest with me because
i know you're very young i want to know
were you fans of saved by the bell had
you heard of it when this project landed
in your lap
i was definitely aware the culture
impacted had but
i was a baby born in 2001. i was
watching hurricane josh
um i hate to say it i hate to ask myself
like that i'm a fetus
and i did not watch the show but i'm
proud that i was aware of it
so at least give me credit for that 100
you get you get all the credit with your
young fresh 20 20
perspective i mean what did you think
when you went back
and watched some of those iconic
episodes from the 90s i think it's
extremely important to recognize that
although that show was so fun and so
wonderful and
served so many people this like warm
comfort
it also was full of a lot of ignorances
and a lot of
things that showed how not evolved the
times were
so what's amazing about our show is we
take everything good from the original
but we have those topical conversations
and we do evolve
through our characters and through our
storylines which i think makes for a
smarter
more enjoyable piece of television i
have a kardashian coming at lunch
shut up he's still in their family josie
i want to tell you you know just kind of
on a personal note reading
your essay in time magazine it really
just touched me and moved me in so many
ways
and i loved that in your essay you wrote
that looking to the future
you're just really excited to be playing
roles um
with people who you identify with what
did it mean to you
to play a character like lexi well first
of all i want to say thank you so much
for saying that that's really sweet of
you that was definitely a very
vulnerable
personal letter that i wrote so i really
appreciate you saying that
it meant everything to get to play this
role i mean it was such a cool
opportunity to get to portray
a character like this that it wasn't all
about her gender identity i think that's
what's so important about representation
now and what we
look to for the work that we need to do
for representation in the future is
getting to have these types of
characters but not making it all about
x all about race all about their gender
all about their sexual orientation
and the way we tell the story in a
dynamic
uh layered way is just so fun to watch
and play
and it makes my job easier and it's just
so fun for me and i
really really enjoy being on the show
ready for my party saturday night i got
dj khaled's baby to make you a playlist
it's okay timeout i love that lexi
is the most popular girl in school she's
got the
fiercest wardrobe in town talk to me
about the role of lexi
and how it contrasts from how
transgender actors have been you know
portrayed on screen in the past
well i think so much of trans
representation as we've seen in the past
as connotations of negative stories
and is usually only telling uh trans
stories through their struggle
and when it's not their struggle it's
through this bad lens
that they're causing some sort of harm
or harm is coming to them
so getting you to tell a genuine well
written storyline
about a person who's a mean girl who's a
fashionista
who's a bad belief but then also happens
to be transgender
is the coolest thing in the world um and
i think
tracy wakefield and our writers and of
course
them giving me the opportunity to be a
producer on the show was able to to make
this story
as authentic as possible and i think
people will be extremely extremely
pleased with that
you only know how bayside works for kids
like you hot kids
privileged kid privileged kid i know
that you're a producer on the show
are you in the writer's ears giving
ideas and and sharing insight about like
what would actually make this character
super relatable and authentic to me
for sure i mean i had so many
conversations with tracy
back and forth up until receiving all
the outlines
and then literally doing surgery on some
of the scenes that
had to do with her identity because of
how important it was to tracy and how
important it was
to me to tell the most authentic story
what's great for this about me but not
necessarily for the writers is that i
actually worked with like eight of the
writers on a show called champions that
i did before this
and so i have all their numbers and i
literally text them like
every single day or i did on set and was
like hey what if we tried this so
i don't know they might hate me by now
but they say they love me
they know my voice so well so i don't
have to do that much work but
it's so great that i have a seat at the
table can you give me an example of a
scene that you
certified i think it was really
important to us to
portray lexi as like this mean girl who
had all these friends but then somehow
find a way for her to develop this like
beautiful friendship with daisy
and it just seemed weird to us that she
would
come to daisy if she had all these
friends so i had come up with the idea
in conversation with tracy that she had
been like
this sort of celebrity that was afraid
of having all these things
leaked from her and i think that kind of
drives the story line in episode three
where like
throughout the episode you see her kind
of peeking in uh to all these
conversations and then realizing that
she's so scared of being ousted for her
crush
and that is why she develops a
friendship with daisy because she's the
only one she can trust and i think that
creates a beautiful arc
for the show
you